al giorno d'oggi sentiamo molto
spesso parla
ma la domanda è chi è veramente utile
ciao coriano vi pongo questa domanda io
per rispondere a questa domanda penso
che sia molto importante prima cercare
di capire che cosa si intende con
intelligenza artificiale
d'altra parte ognuno di noi sa un'idea
diversa e molto spesso queste idee sono
vengono fuori da dei film quindi magari
qualcuno di noi si immagina delle
fantascientifiche coscienze che vivono
su microchips o dei cyborg pronti a
distruggerci la realtà in realtà è un po
diversa e quello che mi propongo di
raccontarvi oggi è una declinazione più
pratica più operativa di quello che è
intelligenza artificiale
ma andiamo con ordine partiamo da il
significato di intelligenza intelligenza
la parola intelligenza deriva dal latino
intelligere ovvero fare una scelta
ancora meglio fare la scelta giusta ma
certo parliamo di intelligenza
artificiale come fa una macchina a fare
una scelta
d'altra parte le macchine sono sempre
state delle esecutrici ovvero dato un
programmatore che scrive una lista di
istruzioni loro le eseguono in modo
estremamente rapido e senza mai
sbagliare dare la possibilità a una
macchina di fare una scelta di fare una
scelta è un compito complesso perché
implica lasciare la macchina la
possibilità di sbagliare
certo sbagliare è un problema sbagliare
va bene ma capire di aver sbagliato è
un'opportunità capire di aver sbagliato
ci apre la possibilità di imparare da
imparare dai nostri errori ma caliamoci
in un esempio più crea più pratico più
concreto ovvero per esempio distinguere
i cani dei gatti chiameremo quindi
qualcuno o qualcosa intelligente se date
una immagine di un gatto o di un cane
potra dire ok questo è un gatto oppure
ok questo è un cane
certo per noi adesso immediato
ma se ci pensiamo bene non è sempre
stato così quando eravamo bambini non
sapevamo distinguere un cane da un gatto
come facciamo adesso essere in grado a
farlo beh abbiamo avuto un maestro un
insegnante e un genitore con qualcuno
ogni volta che passavo un cane ci diceva
guarda quello un cane ogni volta che
passano un gatto diceva guarda quel un
gatto
abbiamo quindi imparato dall'esperienza
abbiamo quindi appreso in modo
automatico da di certi esempi come
distinguere una cosa da un'altra
ispirati da questo processo abbiamo
cercato di imitarlo anche nelle macchine
ovvero data l'immagine di un cane come
fa un intelligenza artificiale a dire ok
questo è un cane non è un gatto
beh all'inizio quando inizializzata
quando viene creata e proprio come un
bambino non ha la minima idea di come
distinguere le une dalle altre
la chiave è porre all'intelligenza
artificiale una serie di esempi da cui
apprendere da cui imparare
ovvero una serie di immagini di cani con
la scritta questo un cane una serie di
immagini dei gatti con la scritta questo
un gatto attraverso quindi l'esperienza
gli esempi che una macchina può capire o
meglio che una macchina può almeno
imparare a fare delle discriminazioni
sulla base di questo principio sono
state formulate tantissimi esempi alcuni
che sono sicuro molti di voi hanno
utilizzato per esempio chi di voi non ha
mai utilizzato snap ciato instagram
ecco questi sono dei chiari esempi di
applicazioni di intelligenza artificiale
perché quando noi ci facciamo un self i
con gli effetti di slanciato di
instagram
c'è un intelligenza artificiale che
prima di tutto comprende che c'è un
volto nell'immagine che una cosa non
banale e dopo di che comprende dove sono
gli occhi la bocca e comprende la sua
posizione tridimensionale su un'immagine
che è piatta e su di essa applica dei
degli effetti più o meno più o meno
interessanti più o meno simpatici come
il mio preferito
l'uomo fragola d'altra parte o meglio
ancora un altro esempio
siri o google assistant che il suo
analogo di android ecco questi sono
degli esempi di intelligenza artificiale
applicati al riconoscimento vocale
ovvero questi codici questi algoritmi
comprendono e hanno imparato a farlo
sulla base dell'esperienza a distinguere
da un suono dei fonemi e da dei fonemi
delle parole e da delle parole delle
frasi non solo ma da delle frasi
comprendere il significato e cercare di
rispondere in modo corretto
esiste però un applicazione
dell'intelligenza artificiale che io
ritengo straordinaria che mi sa quando
l'ho scoperta mi ha affascinato
tantissimo e sulla quale ho avuto anche
l'onore di portare un piccolo contributo
di lavorarci
ecco siamo nel campo della medicina e si
tratta di ridonare a persone che non
hanno più la facoltà di muoversi
non più la facoltà di muovere alcun
muscolo e quindi di parlare la capacità
di comunicare
esistono infatti delle patologie come
per esempio la sla che portano alla
progressiva perdita del controllo
volontario motorio del corpo non mi
addentrerò nel come evolve la patologia
fatto sta che mano a mano si perde la
capacità motoria del corpo prima le
braccia poi le gambe poi il busto
infine anche il volto come
e da qui la impossibilità di poter
parlare nei casi più gravi si arriva in
uno stato denominato clis completa in
loc dean state in questo stato non è più
possibile fare alcun tipo di movimento
nemmeno micromovimenti nemmeno muovere
gli occhi e in questo stato
ovviamente non è più possibile
comunicare da un punto di vista esterno
se noi guardiamo queste persone è come
se fossero in un coma perché non
rispondono a niente ma c'è un'importante
differenza
queste persone in realtà hanno un
cervello perfettamente funzionante c'è
sto dicendo che queste persone pensano
sognano hanno dei desideri hanno voglia
di comunicare hanno voglia di parlare
non so se vi è mai capitato di fare un
sogno in cui volevate parlare volevate
gridare ma non usciva niente dalla
vostra bocca
ecco queste persone vivono una
condizione molto simile ma è proprio in
casi così estremi e così particolari che
l'intelligenza artificiale può venirci
in soccorso o perlomeno può esserci di
aiuto
d'altra parte se siamo riusciti a
insegnare una macchina distinguere un
cane da un gatto mostrando una serie di
esempi perché non mostrare a una
macchina una serie di sì una serie di
pensieri di sì e dei pensieri di no
osservando dei segnali cerebrali
provenienti dalla testa quindi ed è
proprio così che è stato fatto ovvero
abbiamo costruito una serie di esempi su
cui la macchina potesse imparare una
serie di esempi di pensieri mi spiego
meglio abbiamo posto a queste persone
delle domande delle domande la cui
risposta poteva essere solamente sì o no
come per esempio
roma in italia oppure due più due fa 9
su questa serie di esempi abbiamo
costruito un intelligenza artificiale in
grado di distinguere il si o meglio il
pensiero del sì dal pensiero di un no
sto dicendo che per queste persone la
cui comunicazione era assolutamente
impossibile era assolutamente
impensabile anzi adesso di nuovo
possibile
certo è possibile ancora un livello
abbastanza primitivo a livello a di sì e
di no
in un certo senso è come se fossimo allo
stadio di galileo
abbiamo appena iniziato a puntare il
cannocchiale sulla luna ma questa è una
base è una base che dà speranza ed è una
base che consigliò i no ci può
permettere di ri instaurare un rapporto
con queste persone c'è una cosa ancora
più straordinaria ovvero che questa
tecnologia è stata presa da diversi
gruppi di ricercatori per investigare
come stanno queste persone perché non
era più possibile comunicare con loro e
quindi è stato sottoposto a tutte queste
a un insieme di queste persone di questa
patologia un questionario un
questionario standard psicologico con
una serie di domande
la compilazione di queste domande alla
fine restituiva un punteggio ovvero il
punteggio qualità della vita insomma è
un modo scientifico per dire oh ma come
va
e questi sono i risultati
straordinariamente persone in questo
stato molto difficile da immaginare
l'ottanta per cento di queste persone
giudica la propria qualità della vita
tutto sommato soddisfacente o
addirittura buona non esiste una chiara
spiegazione scientifica di questo
risultato
alcuni sostengono che derivi dalla
condizione di rilassatezza che provano
queste persone a causa della paralisi
altri sostengono invece sia merito della
nuova possibilità di interagire di
comunicare soprattutto con i loro carico
le persone che li amano che continuano a
stare intorno a loro
volergli bene al di là della motivazione
io credo che sia una straordinaria
evidenza della resilienza dell'uomo
ovvero ovvero appunto della capacità
dell'uomo di poter trovare motivi per
vivere forza di vivere e felicità anche
in stati estremi
insomma per dirlo in una sola frase
siamo molto più forti di quello che
pensiamo
[Applauso]